What I have here is a regular grid of dots.
We are going to look at how those dots move
in the image plane of a camera as the camera
moves.
Here we have the camera looking at that grid
of dots; and I am going to move the camera
towards the left — that's the negative X
direction — and we can say that the dots
all appear to move in the positive X direction
in the imagine plane. Come back to the middle
and now I move the camera in the positive
Y direction. We see the dots all appear to
move upward in the frame; that's in the negative
Y direction. If I move the camera downwards
towards the plane of the dots, we see that
they all tend to be expanding outwards from
the center of the image plane. And finally,
if I rotate the camera around its Z axis — what's
called the optic axis — we see that the
dots all appear to rotate around the center
of the image plane.
Consider that we have a camera looking at
an object, in this case a ball.
We attach a coordinate frame to the camera
in a way that we should be quite familiar
with now. We call that coordinate frame C.
Now we can define the position of the ball
with respect to coordinate frame C.
Now we can consider that the camera is able
to move, and it's moving in three-dimensional
space so we can have potentially a velocity
in the X, Y and Z directions, and it can rotate
about the X, Y and Z axis.
We can project the three dimensional position
of the ball into the image plane and we obtain
the coordinate u,v.
Let's demonstrate some of these ideas in MATLAB.
We are going to create a camera object, and
we've encountered this before. It's a pinhole
camera with default parameters, and these
are shown here. I am going to create a point
in the world and it's going to be X coordinate
of a metre, Y coordinate of a metre, Z coordinate
of five metres. Transpose that so that it
is a column vector. Now I can project that
three-dimensional world point onto the image
plane of my camera, and it is at this coordinate
- 672 for u, 672 for v.
Now I am going to project the point again,
but this time I am going to shift the camera.
I can do that with the ‘tcam’ option — the
transform of the camera — and I am going
to move the camera 0.1 metres in the X direction.
So the ‘transl’ function we've encountered
before creates a homogeneous transformation
that represents a translation. There's no
rotation in this translation: 0.1 in X direction,
0 metres in the Y direction, 0 metres in the
Z direction.
Close that last bracket off, and here is the
point.
I've moved the camera a small amount in the
positive X direction, and we can see that
the u coordinate has reduced. The point has
moved toward the left in the image.
I can compute the sensitivity of this motion
by taking the difference between the shifted
point, and its original position, and dividing
by the amount that I moved the camera. This
sensitivity indicates that for every metre
that I move the camera in the positive X direction,
the projection will move -160 pixels on the
image plane.
We can repeat this process for other kinds
of camera motion.
Here is our projection function of the world
point, and I am going to now translate the
camera in the Z direction. Subtract the original
position and divide by 0.1, and here we see
that if I move the camera 1 metre in the Z
direction, this particular point will move
32 pixels in the u direction, 32 pixels in
the v direction. I can replace that translation
with a rotation. Let's rotate the camera,
say 0.1 radians around the X axis and repeat,
and in this particular case the projection
of the point will move by 40 something pixels
in the u direction and 850 pixels — a significant
amount of motion in the v direction.
What we've seen is the relationship between
how I move the camera and how the projection
varies on the image plane.
A more intuitive way to visualise what's going
on here is to display the flow field, and
the flow field is defined for this particular
camera and I parse in the velocity of the
camera. So in this case I am going to parse
in the spacial velocity of the camera, so
that's a six vector and it has got unit velocity
in the X direction. The flow field looks like
this. It's saying that if the camera is moving
in the positive X direction, then every point
in the image will be shifted towards the left.
If I change the camera velocity to be unit
velocity in the Y direction, then the flow
field looks like this. If my camera is moving
in the positive Y direction, which is the
way I defined my camera coordinate frame — the
camera is moving downwards in the world — then
every point in the image appears to move upwards.
Now let's change the velocity to being unit
velocity in the Z direction. Imagine the camera
is moving towards the scene. Now the flow
field looks like this. We have this very distinctive
radiating pattern coming from the centre of
the image plane.
The final example that I want to show you
has got zero translational motion and it has
got unit rotational motion around the Z axis.
I'm rotating the camera and in this case,
every point in the scene appears to rotate
around the center of the image plane.
Let's consider that we have a regular array
of points and the camera is moving in the
positive X direction. It's got a positive
X velocity component. What we observe is that
all the points in the image move uniformly
toward the left. Now let's consider a more
interesting example where the camera is moving
forward. And now what we see is this interesting
radiating effect, a bit like the Star Trek
warp speed effect. We see that points towards
the edge of the image are moving faster than
points in the middle of the image. The centre
of the image we call the focus of expansion.
It's the point from which all of the pixels
appear to be radiating from. Consider now
that we rotate the camera in a positive direction
around the Z axis. If I’m holding the camera,
that will correspond to me rotating the camera
in a clockwise direction. The pattern of pixel
velocities is now quite different. We see
that each pixel's velocity is tangential to
a circle centered on the middle of the image.
So far, we've considered a fairly contrived
example. We've imagined this camera moving
towards a uniform array of dots. The real
world is not like that, but we can compute
this optical flow phenomena for real image
sequences. Here we see some imagery which
is captured from an unmanned aerial vehicle,
a flying robot if you like. The robot is flying
at pretty much constant altitude, and moving
in very much a straight line. Each of these
green arrows indicates the direction that
a point in the image is moving from one frame
to the next. This pixel motion has been greatly
exaggerated from frame to frame. A point is
only going to move a few pixels. Although
the average pixel velocity is downwards within
the image, we can also see that there is some
side to side motion, and this would indicate
then that the robot is not exactly flying
a straight-line path - perhaps is being buffeted
by wind gusts which is causing its hitting
angle to change a little bit.
Another example, this one which is more three-dimensional, is taken from a camera on a car moving along
a road, and there are a lot of parked cars
at the side and there are a lot of trees.
What you'll notice in this particular case
is that objects that are far away cause relatively
little optical flow, where objects that are
close by cause a large amount of optical flow,
whereas objects that are close by cause a
large amount of optical flow. We can see this
radiating optical flow pattern again. We can
see that the vectors all appear to radiate
from a point in front of the car, which we
call the focus of expansion. That's the point
in the world that the car is heading towards.
Another thing we will notice occasionally
is that the optical flow vectors bounce up
and down crazily, and that's because the car
was driving over a speed bump. So the car
is pitching up and then pitching down. That
causes an additional motion component, which
is superimposed on top of the optical flow
due to just pure forward motion.
This is a very very powerful illusion. I am
inside a rotating drum and my eye can detect
the motion of this drum. My eye and my brain
are computing what we call optical flow, and
this optical flow that's caused by that rotating
drum, is the same sort of optical flow that
I get if I rotate my head this way, or I rotate
my head that way. And this particular illusion
causes me to feel a little bit uneasy because
the information that I get with my eyes — the
optical flow — tells me that my head is
moving from side to side but the gyroscopic
sensors in my ears tell me that that's not
happening. So there is a disconnect between
what my ears are telling me about my attitude,
and what my eyes are telling about my motion,
and that leads to the sensation of sea sickness
or slight nausea, which is why I am hanging
on very tightly to these rails.